what makes a beautiful shot
what makes a beautiful shot well
beautiful
is a tricky word i think um
yeah that's boy i don't even know how i
would begin to answer that because a
beautiful shot
well you know there is a basic thing to
to me
uh backlit something that's backlit if
the light is behind
coming through uh that that's always a
good place to start but
beauty is such a strange word because
there's
i think at least for my work
working in long-form narrative i think
beauty is all relative to the story so
it's really what what
keeps you my translation i suppose of
that question would lean me toward like
what
fits uh a scene like what
what if the emotion of the scene is
loneliness
you know the word beauty is gonna be
interpreted differently what's a
beautiful way to shoot loneliness or a
beautiful way of shooting
madness you know and then so is beauty
actually beauty or is it uh
i think i think it's all just relevant
to the story and the intention of a
moment or a scene
and so there are spots where ugly is
beauty
you know which i which i like i like i
like that it's malleable
and it should be because you know
any director is going to interpret the
same script
in their own way any cinematographer is
going to interpret it their own way
so beauty yeah beauty
it's interesting because i have a
director who maria marioli
who she has an aesthetic that i really
like
and so shooting with her is
pleasurable because it's almost it's
just
it's almost the cleanest definition of
beauty in a way like
we've we've tended anything that we've
done together we've just tried to make
beautiful in the most simplistic terms
you know like
beautiful people beautiful places
beautiful costumes beautiful light
and it's really fun to do that i really
love
doing that but she might be the only
director who i work with where i ca the
word beautiful
even fits everywhere else it just feels
so
relative to the moment like what's the
the intention
almost becomes more important than
beautiful so i feel like that's not
much of an answer but it's so hard the
word beauty
for my jaw i actually you know what i'll
add to this
i was um on facebook i have a few
cinematography groups that i was part of
and i noticed every time i would get off
i would be on there for a little bit and
every time i'd get off i'd feel really
bad about myself
and it was because people were posting
beautiful stills from commercials
music videos whatever it was and i'd
look at their stills
and i'd just be like i've never shot a
still that looks like that that looks
beautiful like that
and it really was getting to me
and then i was working on a show and i
was thinking about it as i was on set
and i was like well this shot could be
it's not beautiful and i was like wait
wait no no this isn't supposed to be
beautiful
like the the last show i shot penn 15
that was one of the mantras is like no
beauty
it is not a place for beauty and that's
you know we had a new gaffer come in
for season two and he'd light a close-up
and we'd be working on it
and he'd bring in a little fill light or
whatever an highlight or rim light
whatever and i'm like no no
no you we got to get rid of that that's
too beautiful like if shots were
beautiful on that show
we would axe them we would we would try
and ugly it up
a little bit so yeah so on that show
beauty was the enemy
in a way which is tricky
that's interesting i watched both
trailers season one season two and it
looks hilarious i'd love to watch the
the full show is that because it's
supposed to show the awkwardness of like
junior high
or what i'm not sure exactly how old
they are but yeah
yeah they're they're junior high and
yeah it's
it's a show about awkwardness and
and it's supposed to play real you know
it's it's a weird setup there are 30
year olds playing 13 year olds
with other actual 13 year olds but we
wanted to play it
naturalistic and so
you don't want like you don't want
close-ups to look beautiful you don't
want i mean
there was nothing about puberty that
felt beautiful to me
and so that was a big part of it and so
we we
uglied up the image a lot we we added
noise
we shot with noise in camera and then we
added grain
and we would make sure it wasn't too
saturated and
it was it was a real dance but that was
the
the mantra is and that came from from
the creators they were like we don't
want a beautiful show we want this to
there was a show
a movie that we used as reference
welcome to the dollhouse
which is yeah and it's a great like 90s
indie movie
and that's what they kept saying is like
how would we shoot this as a 90s
indie movie where we don't have
resources what you know
how would we approach this and making
sure to not make something beautiful
because often
i think that's what a lot of
cinematographers
think their job is is to make beautiful
images and i
don't think that's the job i think i
think you're there
to create help create a story and help
hold up a story and that the the
atmosphere that you're creating the
visuals you're creating now that doesn't
mean beauty doesn't belong there
but it's it's in conjunction with the
story
where are the relationships where are
the characters where's the arc right now
and leaning into beautiful shots
that would be great on a reel i think is
a
very dangerous way to work
is that because you're always kind of
competing with yourself and you're
taking yourself out of the
trueness of the story in terms of how do
you mean
well you know because i was thinking
like cinema verite you know you're going
to just you not
you just want to show exactly what's
there right but so much of it now is is
trying to top
not only your work but other people's
work whether it's on instagram or
whatever
right yeah no that's interesting because
there is yeah
there is i mean there is something and i
do think about this is how to make
something stand out
in a in a world full of images
and who are you comparing yourself
against
i think i had i had i almost feel like a
an aesthetic breakthrough watching the
show atlanta
i because i was working in all these
half hours which i never
thought that's where i'd end up but i've
been chewing all these half hour shows
and i was struggling i was like how can
you like i want to make something that's
cinematic that still feels like i'm
shooting a feature and how do you
work that in but i think
you know then seeing a show like atlanta
and there was another show at the time
i loved dick it was on amazon and very
different shows
but both of them have a rawness to them
and atlanta
the way that they shoot that is amazing
they're they're
basically trying to break the sensor of
the alexa they're under exposing by
several stops
and then pulling it up so that they're
pulling out the noise
which is the opposite of how you're
taught and the opposite of how
most people are shooting for clean and i
want everything
there's a perfect eyelight and a rim
light and then atlanta came along
and it's so it looks like somebody you
know buried it underground for a month
and then
dug it up and dusted off and like here's
your show
and i loved it because it has a
personality it fits
with the the show like the storyline the
characters
they're broke and they're struggling and
i
for me it really i felt like
it almost it was like i took training
wheels off of my bike
because i was shooting these shows for
people and they're
they're for other people you know show
runner
or a production company or whatever
directors
and so i was like well i don't i was
like very careful oh what about noise
people have a weird reaction to noise so
you have to shoot clean make sure
there's enough light
and then i was like well wait now i want
if they can do this and this is my
favorite show i've seen in
years then what can i do
for my shows that helps them and you
know
then i started to look at a lot older
lenses and
i started to really push myself a little
bit more
in terms of not attaching to beauty like
don't
don't let beauty be the leader i think
that became a big part of my mantra
not to say i won't shoot beauty but
there needs to be a reason for it to be
beautiful
and i find it interesting that you're
not interested in documentary or it's
not that you don't like it but that
you're more drawn to narrative
yeah you know i i love documentaries um
i but part of what i am drawn to with
filmmaking
is the creation of atmosphere and i
think in documentaries you can
absolutely do that
but i'm not as good at it so i
i have a friend who is a great
documentary filmmaker
and i like watching him because it it
opens my eyes up to the possibilities
because now documentaries are becoming
so
cinematic and that to me is very
exciting
you know that people the way people
shoot interviews now is so much more
daring than how it was just 10 years ago
and so
for doc because i do like the dirtiness
of life
and the dirtiness of images i do think
i've got some good docs
in me to shoot but yeah as of now it
just hasn't hasn't come my way but
i would love to
you